of the processing system cool so
relationships Johnny he said that you
had some comments on relationships at
university so I I broke up with my
girlfriend
just before I went to university okay
because you were going to university
yeah
because I have I remember thinking like
I can't possibly go to university with a
girlfriend
mm-hmm which is why I don't know but so
when I got to you like a few people I
was living with hard at relationship
they were Sicilian I remember thinking
like what are you doing it's like
someone arrives like having not enrolled
on their course right but best decision
I ever made I think how long did the
relationships of the people who you
lived with lust not long at all it was
like the battle of the somme honestly he
was just I remember people get young
just live dry it seems like you should
watch people cheat on each other and it
was just oh yeah there was a lot and
especially the people who were in the
long-distance relationships there for
the long-term man like yeah a week later
you see them just in an orgy with I
think it's what you saying Chris about
like you go to uni thinking I'm 18 month
my honor what's going on I know what I
want I know what my values are you
haven't got a clue
so like hunkering that first year of
your life at university when you're
gonna meet probably the most
concentration of new people have all
these like weird intense experiences of
people even like mate that's my pond
yeah I'm doing that my path Michael you
know I wait experiences like that's a
common experience exactly like what I
use even my bacon-y sort of stuff like
you just need time to figure it out you
don't need to have it's crippling isn't
something else to manage it I think that
that's a really nice way to come in it
because it can quite easily lead to us
sounding like we're saying you should
just spray it around as much as possible
during your time at university which
isn't necessarily right I think what
we're saying is that you should expose
yourself to as many learning experiences
as you can and a relationship is nothing
short of a mitigating factor in that now
a lot of short relationships you
you actually think it's quite good to
good learning experience but if you're
going to look at anything you would take
some statistics and you would then model
what you're going to do off the back of
your statistics I would love there to be
a representative sample of how many
people arrive at University with their
girlfriend or boyfriend that they had in
college and what the drop-off rate is
because mine lasted until did you arrive
at uni with a girlfriend and that that
was like my first main girlfriend as
well right so I was like a card like you
know you've got this sense of belonging
you've got this kind of I'm never had a
girlfriend before I don't really know
how to do her name I'm naturally oddly
sentimental in any case so that kind of
all was a perfect storm of me just not
letting go and it was just I ended up
sacrificing so many experiences a uni
and that's not turning down girls to
sleep with although obviously that was
part of it it was just stuff like that
that person is a different stage of
their life than you are even if they're
at a different University it's a
different stage of their life freaks
it's a different place and you end up am
I gonna go to this cricket social no I'm
not my girlfriend's off it's mine it's
like so my 21st birthday for instance
was another girlfriend who was spent
with my then girlfriend crying to me on
the phone because I decided to go out
with my mates instead of going to see
her at my 21st birthday so I didn't have
a good 21st birthday at all regardless
of whether I was with her or still at
University and I'm just managed to
remotely mess it up really like Renee's
you know I think yeah like just I think
we need to me and this this shouldn't be
this shouldn't classes like if you are
in a relationship you should get rid of
it I think the the best model for this
is if you're in a relationship when you
go to university and you're confident
that you want to stay in it then do so
but the second that you think that it
that you are unhappy in the relationship
then call it quits there and then
because not only are you wasting your
own life but you're wasting the other
person's life because they can be happy
with someone else as opposed to being
happy with someone who's unhappy with
them even just the headspace that so I
remember like you go to
sort of a there's loads of stuff that
goes on in freshers week parties and
meeting new people and also stuff people
with boyfriends and girlfriends were
definitely in like a less open frame of
mind going there's been new experiences
like what if someone makes a move I
can't do anything I'm gonna have an
awkward conversation
I'm gonna have to say well where were
you last night or I went to this
afterparty
exactly like well no you should go into
the after pipe because you've never been
to one before I exactly yes oh yeah the
predominant theme I saw with those with
people who are in a relationship was
fear anxiety trepidation just like
they're just desperately hanging on to
you what they know it's safe from now on
home relationship yeah and so they're
just like then just not it's like yeah
it's dipping your toe into the whole
experience and being oh it's okay
because I've I've got a girlfriend it's
almost like a excuse or a shield that
mean you very much though I think people
use to a degree of seeing some people
use sports as that as well so that
they'll choose to not do something
social that take somehow of their
comforts oh make no but rugby sorry yeah
because I've got this and it's like well
no hang on you I'm okay I'm on the C
team exactly no one even knows you know
it's fine I think as well falling into a
relationship during and freshers week or
the first few weeks of the like they say
the same as like the you know the first
people you mean you just latch on to you
yeah exactly like there is going to be
no time in your life that you're going
to meet such a wide range of people like
just accept the sheer odds they're in
front of you that the likelihood of you
meeting the person you should be in a
relationship with being within the first
couple of days and also living it on
your floor in your Holst infinitesimal
it's probably pretty low
yeah well you're extremely fortunate
yeah yeah well I mean but that's what
that's in the back of everyone's minds
right what it's all know this is this is
why it's right it's right because we're
so close and you're like no it's not
it's a [ __ ] nightmare because you're
so close I see all the time right like
these guys and girls come to University
and they've just tumble straight into a
relationship because it gives them a
sense
Comfort it gives them this sense of
belonging someone's got their back and
it just turns toxic so very very fast
hmm again what I want to try and get
across isn't getting into relationships
at university isn't necessarily a bad
thing
the problem is clinging on to them once
they're already gone like you know you
know that it's gone and treat it if it
was easy come treat is easy go and
that's one of my primary problems at uni
was a letting go of things like that
like sigh it was very very difficult for
me and so I didn't want to I sort of
grabby fear - just like quickly just pin
something down the site's familiar isn't
it it's young you searching for
familiarity in a part time of your life
where everything's new and nothing stays
the same it's a lovely way to put it I
think as well another another thing is
that your sample size so 18 years old
your sample size if life experience is
so low like you've really at 18 only
been close to the person that you are
right now for probably about two years
because two years ago you were a
completely different person when you to
new GCSE yes I mean so if you if you've
been with it like that
mental is [ __ ] crazy so think about
the fact that if you're in a
relationship for six months at the age
of eighteen so that large fraction of
your life it's a very it's a significant
proportion of the time you've been alive
[Music]
yeah and you go right okay so I need to
try and look upon this and that's the
problem with this perspective I think a
lot of what we're trying to get across
here is the fact that you need
perspective it's horrible because I had
such a lack of self-awareness combined
with a lack of experience and this sort
of I'm so I'm so lucky that my
girlfriend broke up with me before I
went to uni because I and I was upset at
the time forgot about it within a week
because of he's starting that you know
uni and then I was like actually that
unconsciously poorly articulated feeling
of well you've described both of you
like the seeing people in a relationship
and just seeing something a bit held
back about them and a bit like unwilling
to
dive in and the people who were in a
relationship
yeah they'd fallen at the first hurdle
because they're they've like they're in
Kling mode already but then the people
that fall out the second hurdle other
ones that then jump into a relationship
with the first person that they miss
think where do they meet and if I'd the
worst of all scenarios because you've
had you've missed out on months of
experience you've had to navigate a
failed relationship remotely while at
uni potentially some romantic man awful
conversation ruined his own first
birthday
you know my my 21st birthday I remember
getting into another argument I was in
another argument as I was trying to
write like the first set of exam the
first set of assignments for my masters
just looking at masters mmm
sure so masters I don't know it's there
whether you want good it sounds